okay I wish I had my glasses too no no
all right I know but I take my glasses
off for the reaction it's like oh you're
a Kent and Superman yeah I need to see
their let me remove my gloves that good
well I want people to see my face cuz
this is what people want to see this I
mean income yeah I'm not really here to
see you you know what I mean
when it comes to look department I'm
pretty sure I'm significantly better
looking than cat I mean come on just
look at the two of us I am way out of
her League
come on by the way I'm Ryan I'm Kat and
we should have a white trailer day for a
million ways to die in the West the
second red band trailer it's Seth
MacFarlane's movie you know that is I
know sir I keep questioning yours if you
don't know anything you eat family guys
do you think you don't know one thing
sound like do you know this is you know
what this is I'm sorry for interrogating
you so much I saw the first shooter for
this looks funny I can't wait to see it
I can't wait to see it either
well people let's see it say that now
I'm Superman gosh
that's right back yet Oh Seth MacFarlane
stars in this one too hmm strong crude
and sexual content language throughout
some violence and drug material ah sweet
now you put that under your pillow and
the Tooth Fairy will leave me okay me
you very idiot now clean up that
horseshit you working frontier in 1882
is a terrible place in time Oh in
California against be judging by the
song that's really interesting how they
do it oh good million ways to die in the
West you said the time on the animals
diseases you know cholera the - yes a
black [ __ ] welcome a new member to our
community
oh she's so hot into our awesome man
Charlie's there here every year people
God didn't recognize her from here
Oh
people died the Pharaoh died at the fair
somebody and this one is going to die I
love Liam Neeson don't shoot us on sex
night you beat this guy at a gun fight
you're gonna be a real hero I've never
actually fired a gun before
oh shoot
my first vagina is a piece of cake or
something it's that right there oh yeah
it's this from here today oh but that's
just the outside there's these would do
that sometime
this one it looks like a lot of fun oh
wait wait I'm Sarah Silverman no shadows
that's right it's right on the Hat when
I'm good to go okay hello Dawson that
looks like it could be a classic I feel
like you'll stand the test of time looks
better than 10-million that's a bold
statement actually I don't know if I
should say that but I mean suddenly
Farland just about everything he does is
pretty good oh yeah
that's why people love the Cleveland
Show after three seasons mm-hmm kipper
set did you know he produces that Cosmo
ship what yeah that's why the show so
funny he's awesome he is too awesome
actually
yeah I know I'm glad it's coming out in
just a few weeks I'm gonna watch it cat
will you come with me watch it
yeah let's go see it not as friend oh
I'll find someone else
hey Tanner you want to go at your
million ways to die in the West yeah
Taylor all about you all that dude all
about who it's all about you see it's a
90s rap song well if you're new to the
channel she's put it up here so
subscribe so do it do it do it do the
jus that's the work Oh what do you think
the jus dance would be come on cat you
can do this it's not easy you know this
joke to the next show us you might as
well just I don't know what the new
dances I don't know enough Jewish
stereotype I just like the word Jewish
is it it a cool word did you eat cool
you got funny as in tonight like
Filipino you hear someone's Filipino you
don't really take them to serious
services I'm half Filipino I can say
that and I'm not Jewish so I can't say
that part of the hey it's that time of
the video guys shut up Aaron Alejandro
Alejandro Alejandro you have two very
different names Aaron and Alejandro are
you doing
it's not porn while you're looking at so
intently I don't know I just really tiny
fun I was trying to see it I'm sorry you
got mini Romero
we're not my turn yours Oh DOMA there
okay
rushing through the names yeah I did you
wanted to shout out so here it is we're
mentioning you good mention mentioning
your name power of Christ compels you my
compliment man you Romero he said if he
doesn't get a shout out you might turn
himself into a zombie I don't know like
if he wants to kill himself hey don't
shoot yourself in the head because
you'll never come back from the dead or
you know like I don't know I don't want
to get all dark here why would you did
this man expose get exposed why he's
going to find a zombie to get exposed
oh you mean to the Bible well you
usually start some monkeys that's easy
dawn of the Planet of the Apes and Manny
Romero time it so they're gonna be
zombies and does Lindy that would be so
cool heaps and zombies remedies aid
zombies my god dude
now that's even ten times more
threatening somebody thought 12 monkeys
was gonna be and then I saw I never just
like now it sounds like so bad and it's
still a great movie sure sure well
thanks Manny thanks for pitching in on
this man you're gonna get some writing
credit last one sir Jam so jam you
wanted a shout out so here's your shout
out so job that's miss me British I
don't know I was like I was trying to
channel my you McKellen that I wanted to
like American citizen you in the killing
yeah you are sir John
that's good that's pretty good right
yeah I'm staying yeah yours friend
peanut butter ah you see she's sir
peanut butter your sir Jam two together
you know you get the Earl of Sandwich
does a terrible job no wasn't we're
keeping that that's funny [ __ ] you
probably got that out of one of those
100 joke books yeah that's where most of
my comedy comes from literature you live
a hundred jokes so I only have a hundred
joke so we're gonna be done with the
show soon